Alright guys, so, first of all, apologies if you hear some noises in the background, currently it's daytime, so yeah.
So anyways, here's an example for a breaker block, so you can see we have lower low, lower high, lower low.
So this is the last candle before the move to the downside, and then we have market structure shift.
So now, you can see that this, so now what you can do is you can either mark out the breaker with the wick, or just mark out the body, okay, from the body.
I usually mark out from the body, but you can do wick as well.
So, notice that how we have fairly gap here as well, and that is overlapping with the breaker block here, right?
So, price comes back, and it hits this breaker block, and then it goes up, right?
So, you can see that breaker blocks are great to hold, and they are very powerful when there is fairly gap overlapping with the breaker.
So you can see we had market structure shift right here, and we had our entry here, there was also a fairly gap, and also we had breaker blocks.
So, that was a perfect setup.
So, let me give you guys another example.